Blaine harden author of Africa
dispatches from a fragile continent why
is it a fragile continent
well it's fragile because it had a very
brief exposure to colonialism probably
the briefest and in world history
the colonialist came into most of the
continent in 1880 1890 and by and large
they were out in terms of controlling
most of the territory of the continent
by 1960 1963 1964 the place had a very
short and rather violent exposure to
modern initi in terms of nationalism in
terms of the way it's divided and it is
in the process slow jerky process of
learning how to grow into the national
grid that was imposed on it from from
Europe when were you there I was there
from 1985 until 1989 I went for the
famine in Ethiopia I shoot it into the
famine in Ethiopia which was luckily the
it was the worst thing I saw in the
continent because a million people were
in the process of starving to death from
them and related illnesses dying and I
left a in 1989 what were you doing there
I travelled across the region
sub-saharan Africa 45 countries I made
it to about 26 countries I think 26 but
I went to the big countries a lot I went
to Nigeria a lot I went to Zaheer I went
to Sudan 12 13 times Ethiopia Kenya
Zambia I was there to try to explain the
politics and the economics of the place
writing for writing for The Washington
Post did you enjoy it I loved it there
and the reason it was it was so good for
me because I'm a feature writer and
there wasn't a whole lot of news going
on news as its defined by The Washington
Post so I was given enormous freedom to
to travel to do what I want I spent
three and a half weeks doing a story on
the zai
going down the zyre river across as a
year I spent a couple weeks in a truck
with rebels in southern Sudan I went up
country in Ghana to see the family of a
sociologist and talk about the the webs
of the extended family in Africa and how
it helps to hold the continent together
when the governments don't work so great
what are you doing now
I cover Eastern Europe I went to Eastern
Europe last year in July and I studied
polish for two months and then I started
chasing revolutions all across the all
across the region and now I'm in the
process of writing about adjustment how
do you convert from socialized from
social social state-owned world to
privatized world and it's a slow painful
process
how big is Africa at the total of Africa
in population it's about six hundred and
seventy to seven hundred million the the
population is hard to count and some
countries don't like to count because
they come up with more Muslims than the
Christians want more Christians in the
Moslems want that's particularly the
case in the largest country in the
region which is Nigeria and its
population is anywhere between a hundred
and between a hundred million and maybe
a hundred and twenty five million
they haven't counted for at least a
decade how many countries are there in
Africa well in my region they're 45 and
as I said most of them were carved out
of the region by colonial powers at the
other regions how made what's the total
number yeah total number I don't know
there are five or six up above in the
above the Sahara and then there's South
Africa but you're talking about
countries not include like Egypt and
Tunisia and Morocco those weren't part
of my region that's part of the Islamic
Muslim world and South Africa was not a
part of your it's not part of my region
we my newspaper has someone there has
two people there full-time covering that
country and the middle is one person in
the area you covered what what
percentage of population was black the
whole population was black except for
aid donors and diplomats
in in in Eastern Africa there is a large
Asian community Indian and Pakistan
who've been there for four decades and I
think they may amount to three or four
percent of some of the countries Kenya
Tanzania may be it may be less than that
before you went there to report on that
part of the world had you ever been
there before
no I hadn't been I'd always wanted to go
but I'd never been there
what were your how did you change your
thinking about what Africa was what's
the difference between before and after
well it what I learned slowly was how
different Africa is than the United
States I flew into Africa for the famine
and I begin this book by talking about
an interview I had with a mother whose
baby had just died in one of these camps
in the highlands and I talked to her
about where her husband was how she came
to have no food what were her prospects
for the future and she stood at
attention with her dead child beside her
in the arms of a hospital attendant and
wept and said she would stood there all
day if I'd asked her to she thought I
was a doctor or a policeman I was a
strange white man with with sunblock on
my face and a blue baseball hat and the
the distance was really the same
distance I think that one has in looking
at Africa from the living room of your
house and what I tried to do in my time
in Africa was to bridge that gulf by
getting to know that people getting to
know that systems that organize their
lives their extended families their
tribes and to understand how the
governments how the leaders of the
governments have not really served their
interest very well that was the the
major political thrust of my time there
was to understand how the big man
dictatorial style rule works why it
exists and why it must be changed for
the continent to have a chance this is a
very general question but how were you
treated during her four years here well
I was banned for life from Samuel Canyon
doz Liberia my life has lasted longer
than
is so I can go back there now I was
thrown out of Kenya for about eight
hours until President Daniel Mo had
better ideas and decided to to give me a
reprieve and I stayed for two more years
after that I was ordered out of Ethiopia
and those also a reprieve on that order
and the reason these I was banned or
ordered out was because I wrote stories
that challenged the government and in
almost all the countries with the
exception of Nigeria and Botswana you
cannot criticize the leadership in any
way that's known to Western reporters if
you do you're you're labeled as a as a
servant of foreign masters an enemy of
the people
and you're you're tossed out you had to
pick a spot to go visit again one spot
where we're going to be your first
choice it would be Kenya because Kenya
is beautiful and I know that I know I
have friends there unfortunately I think
with the publication of this book I will
not be welcome in Kenya because a lot of
it is critical of the of the current
president there what's your biggest
criticism of that prison he he has a
country that has a future it has an
infrastructure it has educated people it
has a huge tourist industry it has many
resources that could be built on to
build a modern nation it could be a
manufacturing base for all of East
Africa but boy is a typical big man and
he needs to buy or coerced loyalty to
stay in power consequently new investors
everybody who has money has to pony up
to him a percentage to him in his system
the system that he creates in order to
survive there so the future is being
stolen from the country Kenya has this
extraordinary population growth rate it
was measured a couple years ago at four
point one percent how big is to come a
country it's now twenty two million it
will be 44 million in 17 years and so
there's a narrow window of opportunity
in Kenya and it needs to develop its
court its legislature it needs to have a
civil society which it in fact was
building prior to Daniel a voice coming
to power
he has sickened that civil society
weakened it and I think that the future
of Kenya is is very dim unless there
unless there's a change there how did he
get power well he was chosen by his
predecessor Jomo Kenyatta because he was
considered to be not very bright and he
was considered to be a person from a
small tribe that would not interrupt the
tribal balance in the country
the major tribe there is Kikuyu which
was conatus tribe the second largest is
Luo which is a tribe of the traditional
opponents of Kenyatta Moy was chosen
because he was from a small tribe that
was not a factor but Moy is very cunning
he has a great gut instinct for the
political realities how to balance and
playoff drives against each other and he
has survived for now it's 11 years in
the 45 countries that you covered how
many of them have democracies well I
think that there's one right now
it's Botswana what kind of a democracy
is it it's it's a democracy that it's a
it's a lucky country it sits on a
mountain of diamonds probably the
largest mountain of diamonds in the
world it has one ethnic group so it's
homogeneous it's not densely populated
what's the ethnic group
it's the Botswana people they have a
tradition going back in into the ancient
times of listening to criticism and
respond it's responding to it in the the
in the traditional tribal councils
leaders elite have to listen to be
respected to continue to to hold their
position and all of those things wealth
tradition of democracy homogeneity of
ethnic group makes it possible for that
country to to have real democratic
elections real representation and a and
equitable use of the resources of the
country there are small projects in
which
people who pastoral people are helped
with with with extension services with
with health care is universal there and
good schools are good there it is a
country with it with an unlimited future
and it also has money most of these
countries do not have those kind of
resources
what's the population of Botswana oh
it's small it's I think it's just over a
million are there any other countries of
the 45 close even close to a democracy
yeah the the most important point I make
in the book is that it's not impossible
for Africa to build a civil society
where where people have respect for the
law people where people believe in the
law where people believe in institutions
of democracy where people believe where
where there is a level field for
business to operate on it's not
impossible for that to happen and it's
in fact happening slowly and hesitantly
and and sometimes it seems to completely
disappear but then it comes back in
Nigeria the biggest country with 110 120
million people whatever it is they had
the catharsis of a terrible civil war
where it was more or less accepted by
the people that tribal identity tribal
Germany will not work it costs too much
it cost
it ruins the economy and kills too many
people so that's been accepted they've
gotten over that hurdle Nigeria has it's
a major world class oil exporter it sits
on one of the largest seas of natural
gas in the world they have resources
they have the beginnings of a democratic
culture they have enormous ly energetic
and enormously talented people many of
whom with the oil earnings of the 70s
received education that some of the best
universities in the world things are
happening in Nigeria that are hopeful
chapter six the good the bad and the
greedy you mentioned earlier the big man
what is the I want to read some of what
you how you label the big man
what is a big man a big man is a
non-elected leader who stays in power by
coercing or buying a loyalty let me read
a little bit of what you wrote his face
is on the money his photograph hangs in
every office in his realm his ministers
wear gold pins with tiny photographs of
him on the lapels of their taylored
pinstripe suits he named streets
football stadiums hospitals and
universities after him
he carries a silver inlaid ivory mace or
an ordinate ornately carved walking
stick or a fly whisker or a chiefly
stool I can go on
he's called dr. Conqueror teacher big
elephant the wise old man how many big
men are there in Africa almost every
country that's a big man ok with the
exception of the two I mentioned there
are a few others Mauritius which is a an
island in the Indian Ocean does not have
a big men and they've actually had
elections where the person in power has
lost that hasn't happened anywhere else
in the continent it is the pattern and
it's the when the the colonial powers
divided up Africa left states that were
run from the top down although the the
people who took over in the 60s in the
late 50s espoused ideals of democracy in
fact enshrined them in their
constitutions they ran their nations in
the same way from the top down there's
more here is every pronouncement his
report on the front page he sleeps with
the wives and daughters of powerful men
in his government he shuffles ministers
without warning paralyzing policy
decisions as he undercuts the pretenders
to his throne he scapegoats minorities
too short popular support he bans all
political parties except the one he
controls he rigs elections sounds like
somebody who want to get to know did you
know in him my closest encounter with
with one of these men was with Daniel a
boy in Kenya he made a visit to the
United States in 1987 and while he was
here I wrote a story that was on the
front page
up at the front page of the Washington
Post that said torture alleged in Kenya
and it went on to detail how enemies of
Moy people that he said were problems
were arrested were kept in rooms where
they were tortured they were kept
without clothes
in rooms that had about this much water
no bathroom facilities and they were
taken out every few days for
interrogation beaten with sticks and
whips and clubs and chairs and the story
also contained an anecdote about a woman
who whose husband had been killed by the
police and even his death was not
reported to her this was an incredible
embarrassment to to the president of
Kenya when he was in the United States
on a home it had been the first time
he'd been here for a number of years and
the Kenyans who remain a major recipient
of American aid we're looking for some
more money when they can't boy was
looking for some more money so this
story humiliated him he took it
personally and it he basically
short-circuited strip and came home he
arrived in Kenya and he said there are
certain newspaper writers who are using
dirty words about the country they don't
respect the hospitality that's this is
when an order was written for my to toss
me out of the country the order was not
executed for about two months I don't
know why I think because he had been
advised by the people who give aid to
Kenya that it's not a good idea to toss
out American reporters or Western
reporters in any case I was given this
order and Moira proved me the next day I
went to work and I got a call and it was
Moyet on the phone and he said Moore
here do you know where State House is
would you come by tomorrow at 8 o'clock
can you find the place and I said I can
find the place and he laughed and hung
up the phone and I went there the next
day and I in this in my encounter with
him I saw a bit about how he runs his
country I knocked on the door at 8
o'clock sharp
and he opened it double doors
leather-covered and he let me in he
looked at my notebook and grimaced and
he said sit down and I sit down i sat
down and he said would you like to stay
in Kenya and I said yes I would very
much like to stay in Kenya I like it
here and he said okay and he picked up a
phone he said get me in Charl who was
the man who was the principal
immigration officer who signed my order
expulsion order and the man came on the
phone in about quarter of a second and
he said Moy said to this man he said mr.
Hardman you know the one you were
throwing out
give him one year and I held up my
fingers like this and he said give him
two years from me and he hung up the
phone and this was this is how decisions
were made about immigration policy and
then I said you know I asked you some
questions about torture in your country
and he said yes there's never been a
torture in my country I am a much more
moderate intolerant man than mr. Mobutu
in Zaire or mr. Museveni in Uganda and I
said well why do you why do you why are
you so critical so sensitive to
criticism from the outside I am NOT
sensitive to criticism from the outside
he said and after about 15 minutes of
this of my questions in his blanket
denials
he was getting angrier and angry and he
said that's it goodbye and I laughed but
I stayed for two more years in Kenya you
write tough stories about him I wrote as
tough as I could I was convinced the
longer I was there that what he was
doing to Kenya was was terrible
Kenya the legislature there is a very
interesting example under Kenyatta and
in the first years of the country the
legislature worked political scientists
African political scientists wrote wrote
many papers about how it was possible if
you didn't represent the interest of
your people
coffee growing area of the pineapple
growing area you were tossed out in some
years as many as 64 65 percent of the
sitting members of the legislature were
tossed out the ballots were by and large
fair kenyatta who was president at the
time he would not he ran the country as
he wanted to do the legislature did not
dictate foreign policy or the way the
budget worked but local government and a
representative national body of local
interests worked the court system and
inheritance from the British worked as
well the British sent judges there and
the judges taught African British common
law and British common law was enforced
and there was a certain degree of equity
and the way civil society worked in the
rules for the operation of business
under Moy the courts were bastardized
probably the best example of that is
what happened with the the principal
judge of the court system and this man
Cecil Miller was appointed by Moy to
make sure that there were no decisions
that went against the interest of the
presidency if the Chief Justice was a
drunk he was a poor lawyer to say the
least
and at one time at one moment while I
was in living in Nairobi he came to work
very drunk got up left his office went
out in the hallway assaulted one of the
guards in the hallway ran out in the
parking lot took off his pants below his
knees and was trying to get him off and
he was screaming the ione io which is
the philosophy which is the the
the Swahili name for the the slogan of
president Moy which is footsteps and the
senior official in the government came
down and got him into the back of a car
and drove him home and this is the man
who is in charge of the the legal system
in Kenya and this is after the legal
system was really one of the best in
Africa and the court system I mean the
legislature now is such that those who
are thought to have views opposing moy
don't win they simply don't win the free
ballot the the secret ballot in in
primary elections has been replaced by
the cueing ballot which Moy says is a
more African way of voting that in the
in the queueing you have to stand up in
public behind the candidate of your
choice and in doing so you're subject to
tremendous pressure from the government
the government knows how you voted and
it can punish you accordingly or more
importantly could make you think that
you will be published according punished
accordingly and so the legislature has
become a legislative debate has become
absurd absurd and empty people get up
and talk at great length about what a
gifted child loving brave man president
Moyes Blaine harden author of Africa
dispatches from the fragile continent
where did you grow up I grew up in Moses
Lake which is a small town in central
Washington State where'd you go to
school I went to school at Gonzaga
University in Spokane which is 110 miles
away from Moses Lake and I went to
graduate school at Syracuse studying
what studied philosophy and political
science at Gonzaga and that Syracuse I
studied journalism and what did your
parents do my father is a retired
construction welder member of the the
plumbers and fitters union he worked on
Grand Coulee Dam
Hanford atomic works those kind of
places my mother was a grocery clerk and
a mother where did you get your interest
in all this I went to school I went to
college and I read and I got in
stood in faraway lands I I remember as a
kid in college I didn't believe that
they existed I really didn't I sometimes
would go to bed thinking that Walter
Cronkite and these other people were
putting together a big elaborate
deception that they were photographing
sets and the world outside of what I
knew wasn't there and I always wanted
particularly in Africa to go see if it
was there he left Syracuse where'd you
go to work at the Trenton Times which is
owned by the Washington Post and then I
came to the post about two years later a
lot of event the post 11 years other
than Africa and now in Eastern Europe
were review reporting from the United
States strictly and again you mentioned
that Kenya would be your favorite
country to go back to in Africa who of
the 45 and sub-saharan Africa which
would be the one you could care less if
you ever see again well I could I don't
think I could say I could care less if I
ever see any of the countries I was at
where I got to to know the people in it
and understand some of the the way they
live the way they live I would not
particularly want to go to Liberia now
because it is incredibly dangerous and
chaotic and the the future of the
country seems to be very dark for many
years Sudan which is the the largest
country on the continent which has this
split between an Arab Muslim North and a
black Christianized south is has
terrible problems right now it has a
government that is strongly Islamic
strongly confrontational with the
Christian South and the Civil War there
which began in the early 80s continues
and there's a threat of really severe
famine in southern Sudan in the next 12
months as severe as Ethiopia was and
it's very difficult to move in that
country as a westerner because you're
followed you're arrested at a colleague
from the Financial Times who is recently
for for several weeks there so I would
want to go there although I would love
to go there to see what's going on in
your book I think this is that these
four Americans are famous Sudanese this
gentleman right here is is he from Sudan
yes he's from so this guy with a
basketball a short balding guy from
Moses Lake I'm six one and men who Bowl
is considerably taller than I am
my Newt bowl yes he is seven feet six
and three-quarters he said Dinka from
southern Sudan from the town from near
the town of Goguryeo and he was about 19
years old and tending cows for his his
father and for his family when he when a
cousin who played basketball in Khartoum
the capital saw his picture in a paper a
local politician had gone to the town
and the picture appeared in the cartoon
paper and the cousin thought any cousin
of mine who's that tall should take an
interest in basketball and over the next
two years they taught men who'd how to
play basketball the first time he dunked
a basketball it isn't a very big jump if
you're 7 feet 6 and 3/4 inches he caught
his teeth the net ripped out two of them
and that piqued his interest in the game
and he continued to learn and besides
being tall he's a good athlete in the
sense he has terrific timing for
blocking shots and over the course of
the next three years in in Khartoum he
absolutely dominated basketball you
couldn't score he simply could not score
a point if he was being alert and he
came to the United States not speaking a
word of English
never having gone to school having a
tenuous grasp grasp of Arabic at the
time speaking only dinkle well not being
able to write his name in any language
but men at ball is now playing in the
NBA and he's recently traded to this to
the 76ers is an exceptionally talented
exceptionally bright and wonderful guy
and his trajectory out of the swamps in
southern Sudan to the NBA to making a
half million dollars a year
makes now it there's really been nothing
like it in the history of Sudan and
really nothing like it in Africa because
the the the difference the way he grew
up he did not have any education he did
not have any preparation for getting out
of there and he was just tall and he
lucked out and he came out he was he is
so smart that he's managed the
transition when I came and interviewed
him I went to Atlanta with Manute in a
plane which is an interesting experience
because he fits very uncomfortably into
any plane and any seat any class we went
to do a chicken commercial for Church's
Chicken churches Fried Chicken in
Atlanta and we walked through airports
and it was a shocking sight to be with
him because people would just curse
under their breath when they saw him
because his height his height is
breathtaking
but he he he took it in stride he has
taken it in stride but at the same time
he was incredibly lonely he did not have
a wife at that time attempts at
matchmaking had failed in in dinkle and
and he he told me that American girls
don't like to clean and that he was he
was ashamed as a Dinka man that he was
unmarried and didn't have any children
he has since gone back to Sudan a couple
times and with that with the help of a
good friend he met a girl and a dink a
girl who does like to clean apparently
and they're married and they have at
least one child now is it usual to be 7
feet 6 inches tall and Sudan well it is
Dinkas are tall they're probably the
tallest people in Africa 6 feet 5 6 feet
7 is common 7 feet is not unusual I mean
it's not remark a little bit 7 feet 6
and 3/4 inches is as tall as any vinca
that I ever met said that they could
ever remember seeing anybody so he's an
extremely tall person by Dinka standards
why did you pick him to write about and
feature in the book Sudan is a very hard
place to come to grips with it's huge
it's problems in which the ovulation 20
to 25 million
but it is vast it is as big as the
United States he's the east of the
Mississippi it's problems include I
covered everything there from famine to
flood to infections to infestations of
locusts to Civil War its major exports
include gum arabic the basis of [ __ ]
gum it's really one of the essentials
along with camel meat it has oil but the
civil war in the south prevents the oil
from being exploited it really never has
been pumped out of there it's a
potentially rich potentially fertile
place that could be the breadbasket of
the Arab world in fact that phrase was
used often times but its political
problems are such that that has never
been exploited I use Manute because he
is fairy tale counterpoint to what's
happened to his country his
extraordinary success is inversely
proportional to the to the extraordinary
suffering of his country he got out of
there at a whit narrow window of time
between civil wars he never would have
survived if he had left Southern Sudan
two or three years later he couldn't
have left there was a civil war he
wouldn't he would have been a very tall
target I know this isn't a book about
sports but it is interesting what you
write about him once he got in this
country and it he couldn't speak English
not a word of English he said I was not
speaking English not one word and he
learned English very quickly he went he
went to Cleveland University of
Cleveland Knotts Cleveland State he went
to Cleveland State and studied English
but his since he had never gone to
school and could barely read and write
and could barely speak English he was
not a good candidate for college
admission he studied there for a number
of months and then transferred to the
University of Bridgeport in Connecticut
all along they're trying to get him onto
a basketball team right he went there
and he got enrolled Bridgeport
Bridgeport somehow he got enrolled I
don't know how much he learned but he
started playing basketball and he became
an unbelievable presence for that team I
talked to the coach he said that nobody
has had a greater impact on sports at
my college and Manute he blocked who's
blocking 15 to 18 shots a game averaging
which is which means that he totally
dominated and they they did very well
but he couldn't stay there for very long
because the n-c-double-a started to
investigate and say you know what is
this guy doing he's not a he's not
really a very educated person so he left
after one year and he joined a the
Providence seagulls I think for a year
and then he was drafted by the
Washington Bullets you say that he gave
a lot of his money back to the people in
Sudan yeah it's very important to
understand that it's it's so typical of
what is a necessity of life in Africa
Manute earns he probably is the
highest-paid Dinka in the history and
because his people his family have been
dislocated by the war by the fighting in
his region they are homeless they don't
have the cattle which is the basis of
wealth he has built two homes in
Khartoum or purchased two homes and he
has many people living in those houses
his relatives and villagers and
tribesmen and I talked to his manager a
few about a year ago and he said that
Manute you know he sends home a good
part of his money to keep these people
alive
and he he said that this is his
responsibility and we Dinka tribe we
stayed together he says and you know
he's making a lot of money and but he is
still a Dinka how did you get around
Africa mostly by airplane when I drove
it sometimes took a very very long time
were you by yourself most of time um
most of time I did travel with a
colleague a german newspaper reporter
i'm süddeutsche Zeitung and we did some
of our longest trips together and it was
it was great company
how are the airlines well Ethiopian
Airlines ironically is a superb airline
it keeps it scheduled it has new
equipment Boeing 767s it does very well
other airline
are frightening Kenya airlines which had
been one of the best probably the best
in East Africa has a terrible problem
with maintenance and I remember trying
to go to Sudan several times and getting
an hour or two out of the airport and
the old 727 started to rattle and they
turned back and went home
I never was on a plane that crashed my
successor
Neil Henry I think his first flight to
Sudan he his plane in a crash landing in
Addis why do you do this well for one
thing it's it I I'm not a big person on
risking my life and it wasn't dangerous
it wasn't dangerous let me jump in it as
you mean being with president Moy in
Kenya wasn't risking your life not a
chance
no this president Moy is he's not a
great person but he's a smart man and he
he knows as any leader in Africa knows
that you cannot take the life of an
American journalist and continue to get
money from the Western world and Moi's
government just absolutely dependent on
Western tourists and on Western aid it's
it's it's about 66% of the income of the
country hard currency income say that
again it's about 66% of the hard
currency that flows into Kenya comes
from aid and tourists and to do anything
dangerous other than to scold any any
Westerner is very bad policy well I have
that shield I mean the Washington Post
is is it is it's a wonderful shield to
have in Africa anywhere what are the
living conditions for someone like you
as you moved around in those 20 some
countries well they went from very good
in Nairobi which has this long colonial
tradition of comfortable living and
highland highland climate surrounded by
flowering trees and big lawns and all
that stuff is very nice there are
telephones that work nice sweet water to
drink to truly truly terrible I remember
sleeping in the Heil
of Ethiopia during the famine in a in a
room that was about the size of a closet
and the walls are crawling with bugs and
the bed was broken and I had a colleague
from Belgium we were sharing the same
broken bed and it was very cold and
there was no blankets and that's about
as bad as it got but that wasn't for
more than that was just one night
usually the accommodations were better
than that what about the expense I think
I read that you read that night at one
point in the game Nigeria's most
expensive city or the country in the
world or yeah it was Nigeria because of
its oil wealth in the early 70s it's
it's the naira was really worth a lot of
money because it was it was sort of a
manifestation of a hundred billion
dollars coming into a government
controlled economy so the naira was
worth about a dollar thirty really in
real world value over the years is that
oil money was frittered away most of it
one hundred billion dollars ten years
later turned into eighteen billion
dollars of debt which is shocking but at
the same go it went into the pockets of
a lot of people it built some highways
and built some universities it provided
education to the Nigerian elite which is
useful now but a lot of it was stolen as
the Nigerians will admit will will curse
themselves for having stolen it they it
was a it was a precious inheritance
which will probably never come in the
same size again and they they frittered
it away um I forget what I was I'm
talking about the cost of living before
you know it sir then I was immensely
valuable okay but then as that as the
economy went to hell it became one of
many overvalued African currencies but
the Nigerian manhood was somehow
embodied in their currency and they
wouldn't devalue for a long time and
when I first went there the situation
was was absurd the legal exchange rate
was one naira equals one dollar and
thirty cents the black market was 1.1
naira equals about a quarter so if you
were changing money legally
and going into a restaurant to buy
something that had a foreign component
to it like Chinese food a Chinese
restaurant at the legal exchange rate
could cost you a hundred twenty five mil
at a Chinese restaurant with one beer
could cost you a hundred dollars eighty
to one hundred twenty-five dollars
depending on how much fish you had or
that sort of thing a hotel room was very
expensive cab across town could be fifty
bucks and it really was the most
expensive city in the world
they have had been blessed with some
better government some intelligent
economic changes have happened there
they're privatizing such things as their
oil industry which is incredible
considering this is the major earner for
the country they're starting to play it
straight and because wages are cheap in
Nigeria it can grow food it's now one of
the cheaper capitals in Africa is good
value for your money there now Eastern
Europe where you are now where you
stationed in Warsaw compared to Africa
better story more fun less fun what's
well it's interesting Eastern Europe is
so much more developed than Africa and I
Americans who are looking at you know
they follow the news and they think well
this is another troubled part of the
world Eastern Europe's problems are not
even in the same ballpark as Africa's my
feeling is that Eastern Europe will have
problems over the next decade but they
will climb into a certain kind of
Western European prosperity over the
next decade where that's not going to
happen in Africa for 50 or 60 years I
don't think as far as the story is
concerned of course last year during
this extraordinary spate of revolutions
it was it was exhilarating and an
unbelievable historic as we kept writing
in our stories but Africa for me has a
big place of my heart and it's also more
interesting as a writer in this book I
try to to do a little bit more than just
talk about politics and
governments and stuff I try to give a
sense of what the people are like and
how they live and in Africa because it
is exotic it's different and it's
accessible it's accessible people you
walk into someone's house and they'll
tell you what they're doing how they
live what they believe in you can you
can do a lot of sociological journalism
there without a whole lot of difficulty
what's this picture that that is quassia
door oh he's a sociologist my last year
there I wanted to find out how the
African family works I went to Ghana I
talked to many people and I found out
that glossy adoro
was going home to see his folks he lived
up country about 150 miles up in the in
the in the cocoa growing regions have
gone up so I went up there with him and
spent several days and I got to know his
parents his first wife his second wife
and all the hangers on the people you
see over on the right were the various
cousins of a sort as he called them who
were living in his house paying no rent
he was a university professor and that's
his house that's his wife over in the
corner on the left with the baby these
people had come several years before the
pictures were taken and we're still
living there he was giving them a piece
of his prosperity which is the way
Africa works if somebody has a job if
somebody has an income they are
honorbound to share it and in a country
where the government afflicts rather
than governs it's a good way of
redistributing wealth who's this that's
s mo TN o he is the central figure in
what I think is probably the most
interesting chapter in the book he died
of a thoroughly modern illness
hypertension and heart attack and then
his tribe the Luo tribe came gunning for
his body
Luo believed that unless a member of
their tribe is buried properly in
accordance with tribal ritual that they
can be haunted for four years that they
could have car wrecks birth defects dead
animals that people could drown and lay
Victoria so they wanted to bury the body
near the lake where he was born the
first the lady on the right with a scowl
on her face was is s MOT nose widow Wan
Bui
she's the Kikuyu the largest tribe she
comes from a very powerful history
historically important family in Kenya
she wanted to bury the body in Nairobi
she said that we Africans are modern
that essa' that her husband had wanted
to be married buried in Nairobi where he
lived and she could not come to an
agreement with with with s MOT knows
tribal relatives so there was a court
case and it was the most extraordinary
court case while I was living there
it was lasted for six months and the
fundamental the decisive point in that
trial was when the young man there
pictured one of ot jános sons he
testified in the court that the Luo
people were primitive and lazy which is
what he said his father had told him the
court throughout this long trial while s
MOT annals body was on ice in the morgue
the the Luo packed the courtroom they
were by far more demonstrative and
emotional than the Kikuyu when he said
this that the Luo were lazy the
courtroom was filled with hatred and
even the judge who is of another tribe
he was shocked by this and I think that
was the decisive moment in the trial
this young man had said that he belonged
to what I think is an almost fictional
brand of African the non tribal African
and he insulted his his elders to their
face and with impunity the judge
couldn't tolerate that and that was one
of the reasons I think well why the
decision went against the widow that and
the interference from from president Moy
who didn't want the Luo to bust up
Nairobi if they lost and the body was
taken back to Lake Victoria and buried
in the widow said I'm going back to
Kikuyu land with a lot of bitterness as
you've been promoting your book and try
around have you gone to a lot of cities
in the United States no I've just come
back from Poland I'm going from here and
I'm going on from here you get any sense
of the conversations you've had already
what people are interested in here and
are they interested in Africa at all I
think there is an interest in in Africa
I mean it's reflected in the popularity
of movies like Out of Africa and in the
continuing sales of Karen Blixen books
and the biographies of her of stories
about travels in the Dark Continent
there's there's a mystery about it and
an exotic as to it that continues I
think to fascinate people what I try to
do in the book is to use that as a hook
to it's there it's it's it's wonderful
and it's enchanting but it's not the
whole story and I try to use that as the
hook to tell people that Africa is
quickly becoming a big country a big
continent full of freeways in mosques
breweries toxic-waste and the problems
of Africa are not likely to be all that
much different from the rest of the
third world
that's why it needs to have a
governmental system it works on page 281
you stuck a little needle in Lance
Morrow Time magazine let me read a
little bit here you say Time magazine
devoted its most extensive African
coverage of the 1980s 20 pages of purple
prose and color pictures to an essay
that rhapsodize about lions in the tall
grass sagacious pastoral warriors and
miles and miles of bloody Africa time
essayist Lance Morel wrote Africa is
constantly comprehensive great birth
great death the beginning in the end the
themes are drawn like the vivid abstract
height of the zebra and patterns of the
absolute the first question to ask is
whether the wildlife of Africa can
survive that bothered you yeah as I say
in the next sentence I think the first
question to ask about Africa is can the
people survive when Americans Europeans
came to North America there wasn't
somebody from Time magazine asking will
the Buffalo survive and I think there's
there's some comparison there the the
animals are a resource they should be
preserved they should be used by the
people there they bring tourists they
bring hard currency they bring industry
they bring development if they're if
they're conserved and use properly as
has been the case actually in Kenya in
many ways it's been an important
resource for the country but they're not
the fundamental essence of Africa what's
really interesting about Africa is it's
short exposure to colonial influence
it's rapid-fire conversion from a
traditional society into a modern
society every African has its roots in
the village in in its his true home or
most Africans have their roots there
they and they're torn between the
village values the values of their
parents and the values of what they
learn in school between thinking about
the the ancestral inference influence
the spiritual influence of those who
just died the recently departed our
influence are very very important in
African traditional religion and at the
same time they read the Bible or the
Quran that they have competing values
inside themselves across the continent
and this process is is working itself
out day after day the mess that one sees
from a distance the the fact that Africa
is the only region of the world to be
poor thirty years it is poor now than it
was thirty years ago it's probably it
it's health standards are lower it's
less free you cannot say that about any
other region of the world any other
broad region it is uniquely it has it is
an experienced unique failure but inside
every African right now that they are
wrestling with this incredible
transition and that's what the book is
about what if anything to the Africans
you came in contact with think about the
black American now wanting to be called
an African American to tell you the
truth it's not an issue they know it
happened I think some of the people who
read Time magazine
or whatever have heard about it but it
this is not an important issue I think
that it is as hard for black Americans
to go to Africa and get to the bottom of
what's going on there as it is for white
Americans I don't think you have a
particular advantage by a color because
it is it is it is so so incredibly
different and black correspondence from
the United States have gone and I think
their problems in understanding are
really not much different than mine what
language did you speak all throughout
English quite well and I speak French
really really badly I spoke it much
better when I got there but my first two
years were covering famine in Ethiopia
and Sudan and I didn't really get into
French Africa until I'd forgotten a good
part of it so mostly I used English and
a little of my idiots French how work
how were the Africans and the English
language did you you have trouble with
English anywhere no no in in the
countries where English is the the
national language where is that but the
most important ones are Nigeria and
Ghana Sierra Leone Liberia Kenya and
it's widely spoken in most of East
Africa and Zimbabwe and French is the
the normal language in most of West
Africa what's happening in Africa is the
English has been there long enough so
that it's being used now with with real
poetic power and there's an emerging
generation actually this is the second
generation of Africans who write
masterfully and one of the things I
began to do in my last two years there
was read some of the fiction I recommend
to anyone who hasn't read him Chinua
Achebe who has written three or four
incredibly important novels about Africa
from the about colonialism about this
process of change that goes inside goes
on inside their soul and which makes
them unhappy and but he is a great
writer and I actually quote him several
times in my blog can't believe it I just
looked up so we're almost out of time
this hour gun has gone too fast
Howard Simon's deceased former managing
editor of the Washington Post
you write in the acknowledgement section
that he twice helped you to the
newspaper once when I was out of college
and then you say the second time when I
left the paper in a snip I've got to ask
you what that snip was I didn't get a
promotion that I thought I deserved and
so I quit and then I came crawling back
about nine months later and said I want
to go overseas please please please and
they took me back where'd you go for
those nine months I went to work for the
Washingtonians magazine in Washington
which was a good job but it wasn't being
overseas which I wanted to go there's
another interesting little note here
about his daughter Anna an
anthropologist this is Howard Simon's
daughter Anna and an anthropologist who
specializes in Africa she had some
impact on you but she's a wonderful
woman
she came to Nairobi she was going to do
work with with the red Dilley up north
pastoral people she ended up working
with the Somalis but any case she showed
me where a lot of the levers were in
African literature and short-circuited
my research for this book by six months
of enormous value in this book were a
series of long wonderful dinners in
Khartoum and Nairobi with Abdul Mohammed
a good friend and energetic thinker
who helped me understand what I was
seeing in Africa well this guy is an
Ethiopian and he was kicked out of
Ethiopia because of political
differences with the leadership but he's
a scholar and he read very widely of the
African literature and he read my
stories and he told me what was wrong
with them what he thought was wrong with
them and I learned how to conceptualize
it what you have to do in Africa it's
very hard to understand what's going on
so you have to pick a broad theme and go
out and try to fill it in
see how put human beings inside a broad
theme and he suggested various people to
look at various places to go and I miss
him one last person I want to ask you
about Robert Caputo yes he is a
photographer for National Geographic and
has been all over East Africa for the
past 15 years he took many of the
pictures for the book he travelled with
me when I did the mini ball story and he
was very enthusiastic about this book
from the beginning last question what's
the best thing about ever the best thing
about Africa is that people are warm and
they love you on that note there is a
lot more in this book and I wish we had
time to talk about it Africa by blaine
hard reporter for The Washington Post
dispatches from a fragile continent
thank you very much thank you